let's go over a bunch of the more
curious parts of the old hunters some of
these insights are pretty significant
and some are just minor observations but
fact is there's roughly 50 insights in
this video so make sure you keep an eye
on that frenzy meter yeah let's start
with the eye of a blood-drunk hunter in
the same way that the tonsil stone
allows one amygdala to transport us to
the nightmare frontier the eye allows
another amygdala to transport us to the
hunters nightmare I thought it was
interesting to discover that the
amygdala needs something related to the
corresponding Nightmare Realm to
transport us there next the grave that
connects the hunters dream to the
hunters nightmare is also the grave we
find the old Hunter's bone at in the
waking world the old Hunter's bone
allows our hunter to learn the lost art
of quickening which was a technique
particular to the first hunters and
indeed many hunters like Maria dashed
like this in the hunters nightmare
without use of the bone third there's a
deceased amygdala in the nightmare and
as we discover this new realm we learned
that nightmare realms are almost
certainly linked to one another they all
have amygdala they all have winter
lanterns which are based off the doll in
our dream the ship masts in the fishing
hamlet can be seen from the nightmare
frontier and you know even the washed-up
corpse of cause looks kind of similar to
these things in the nightmare frontier
we're learning more and more about these
nightmare realms especially how they
have a very real ability to shape events
in the waking world next up have you
noticed that the old hunters all wear a
garb with the same red cloth on the
inside Maria gurmann their attire is
consistent with the time that they're
from which I thought was a nice subtle
design touch the description of the old
hunters gear also tells us that the
people in this time were quite
superstitious
for instance they used to think that the
beasts blood crept up the right leg
hence they put a belt around the right
trouser leg as pointed out by a bunch of
you in the first video this might
explain why gurmann has a peg leg on his
right some of you suggested that it
might have been amputated in some
outdated method of prevention and
Gherman and his peg leg both are
viewable in the trailer for the old
hunters have a look here you can just
see his peg leg which is curious because
it doesn't just make it any old hunter
wearing Germans garb its gomen himself
walking through the fishing hamlet here
it places go man's character undeniably
within the events that the old hunters
depict and we'll go into a bit more
depth on that later for now though look
at the blood liquors you come across in
the Blood River I used to think that
blood liquors were limited to cainhurst
as if there was some sort of strain of
the old blood that created them because
they're so different to other beasts but
because they're here it makes it more
likely that blood liquors just appear
where a lot of blood has to be present
the blood liquors in cainhurst for
example they likely appeared when the
big slaughter took place there where the
executioner's wiped out all of the
vilebloods
and slaughtered them these blood liquors
would have fed on the corpses but you
know years have passed since then so all
the blood liquors there are skinny and
roaming for food when we encounter them
but the ones here in the nightmare in
the Blood River are fat and bloated in
the old hunters there is a heavy
concentration of items and NPCs related
to the powder kegs the Gatling gun the
piercing rifle the boom hammer all of
these are weapons that the old hunters
use and all of it is going to help a lot
when we're putting together a timeline
for the things that we see in this
nightmare
take Lawrence for example the fact that
he appears in the Nightmare on fire
might be because this is how he died
maybe he died to the molotovs of the
powder kegs maybe in the purge of old
yharnam perhaps to speculation of course
the Gatling gun hunter who we find in
the cave is described by his weapon as
being the youngest of jurors three
companions and he's wielding a portable
version of the Gatling gun that juror
operates in old yharnam
given his relationship to Jura I find it
really curious that he too seems to be
protecting the beasts why else would he
be standing at the entrance to the
dead-end cave with his back turned to
four or five deadly beasts hiding in the
cave behind him and we see this behavior
in the saw spear hunter of old yharnam
as well who I feel pretty comfortable
now calling one of jurors companions
when you reach Simon outside the first
shortcut you can actually just kill him
here if you want his bow blade weapon as
soon as possible and don't worry about
the key he gives you later it will
appear in the spot that he usually gives
it to you another NPC
I should mention is Volta if you crush
five vermin and reload the area to
acquire his helmet his name and
appearance will change to reflect that
when you summon him he becomes a
helmetless Volta the Beast eater his
duties apparently have been passed down
to you in addition your league stance
also changes to have you place your hand
in front of your heart before we start
talking about Ludwig do you remember
this snail girl that fell from the sky
I'm sure a lot of you put together that
she fell from the above water world
above our heads that's not able to be
seen from this perspective and I even
got a shot of her falling from a
distance just to make sure that's where
she's coming from someone pointed me to
this video recorded by reddit user dr.
xanthine MD who discovered that you can
actually revive the snail girl using the
madara's whistle on her corpse it must
activate a part of the hitbox that's
untouched bull or something because you
can't damage her otherwise now until
ludwig how many of you had this little
blood corpse survived the fight it's
surprisingly difficult to keep him alive
and altogether pointless really he just
chuckles to himself once the fight is
over and if you look closely at Ludwig
you do realize a few things he has eyes
on the inside of his little growth here
and he's also wearing what looks to be
the executioner's garb
and his moonlight greatsword is strapped
to his back during phase one it's really
cool to see that he retains a bit of his
humanity when he lays eyes upon it if
you leave Ludwig's head alive after
talking to it and reload your game
you'll reappear to find that Simon put
Ludwig out of his misery instead there's
an arrow through his eye a couple of you
guys in the first video pointed this out
to me and I thought it was really cool
but it was only after I watched a German
spies playthrough that I figured out how
to get the most dialogue out of these
characters and you know that's
interesting information for me since I
need to record this dialogue you should
check out a German spies playthrough by
the way he's got like one of the most
knowledgeable playthroughs of the DLC
out there and he uses some pretty
overpowered techniques moving on past
Ludwig did you know that if you die
outside the bell-ringers room then he'll
say this unending death awaits those who
pry into the unknown up ahead in the
main cathedral chamber we discover that
the all popular how to pick up fair
maidens has been ordered in bulk by the
folks in the nightmare must have been
recommended by Gherman or something one
of these fair maidens here is dressed in
white and recites the same phrases that
vicar amelia did logically this is
amelia and logically she entered the
nightmare after we killed her she prays
in a different location now but she's
still potentially praying at Lawrence's
skull sends the elevator up without you
on it go underneath and you'll find
Lawrence's human skull and the church
cannon one of the coolest little details
on the elevator is the surgery altar
itself putting aside all of the
symbolism involved when we insert eyes
into the inside of the skull and ascend
into the heavens how many of you
actually noticed that there is a beast
underneath the table I caught on to this
when I read a tweet by Hellkite Drake
another uploader who you should check
out the Beast under the table reminded
him of the Beast in the opening cutscene
of blood-borne when you get the blood
transfusion
and I gotta agree the whole scene here
symbolizes to me that latent beast hood
is always a threat lying in wait but
it's also something that the church
awakened through their experiments worth
noting also is the book the bell and
this hat mask thing that looks curiously
like Willems moving up to the research
hall let's take a look at these statues
it's getting to the point now where we
can sort of notice these trends in
blood-borne zarqa texture and I'm
starting to see these hunched over
shapes everywhere these things in the
fishing village the fish men in the
village the alien statues in the
cathedral they really like this shape in
blood-borne when we finally finish
Adaline's questline she shares the
milkweed rune with us on the extra life
wiki someone has written that the
inscription of the rune resembles the
letters H P which could be a reference
to HP Lovecraft whose work is clearly an
inspiration for blood-borne in fact the
story of the fishing hamlet is
incredibly similar to love crafts horror
novel the shadow over Innsmouth which a
lot of people have pointed out to me in
the third videos comments section the
plot details a secretive town humanoid
fish men and the notion of human
sacrifice so pretty similar but speaking
of great bodies of water in the fishing
village as pointed out by commenter
iskar l1 the word Locke from Locke
shield means lake in Irish or Gaelic and
of course this is all behind the giant
clock tower that Maria guards in an
earlier video we pointed out that the
hands aligned to point to the great lake
rune but what about the other runes here
well there are a bunch of them and some
are missing most are there but there is
one here that I don't recognize it's
this massive squiggles and there's not
another rune in the game like this right
the closest thing I can find are the
clockwise runes but even they don't have
these shapes and it's weird because from
soft had a bunch of runes they could
have used
here they didn't use all of them so why
put one here that doesn't exist in game
it's just making me curious thinking
like there's something we haven't found
yet and I should take this moment to
point out that no one has found the
level 3 guidance rune yet the official
DLC guide does tell us that it exists
within the depth 5 root chalice dungeons
so if you're one of the rare rare people
who enjoy doing the chalice dungeons
then get out there and find that rune
let's move on to Maria she's a really
interesting character with curious
motivations and a fascinating background
the rakuyo weapon she uses lists her as
a distant relative to the queen of
cainhurst and even the evelyn pistol she
uses is a pistol favored by the
cainhurst nights the rakuyo we find in
the well was her weapon that she
allegedly threw away when she could
stomach it no longer it's a simple
weapon it's not a blood blade like the
chikage but we do know that Maria gave
in to her thirst for blood since she
certainly fights with blood in the boss
fight and even the Goblet beside her
looks as if it had blood within it
there's also a picture beside her but
the glass is so shattered that it's
almost impossible to make out what it is
there are a lot of other cool details
with her
for example the way she lets go of your
hand here reminds me of the way you hold
your hand up to the doll to level up
only an honest death will cure you now
she says and I take this to mean that
only truly breaking your spirit in a
fight against her will stop the hunter
coming back
she also says a corpse should be left
well enough alone which might injustice
to the corpse of cause at the end of the
fishing Hamlet she is clearly aiming to
protect this corpse and must have had a
huge amount of distaste for what the
hunters did here and for all the hunters
coming through remember that grave that
overlooks the corpse of cause on the
cliffside the one with the lumen flower
placed upon it I'm almost certain that
Maria placed this grave and
was here because she's done the same
thing within the astral Clocktower room
for this coffin here and also because
the balcony key tells us that Maria
hoped Adeline would find comfort in the
faint breeze that carried the scent of
flowers from the outside so her use of
flowers here is pretty well referenced
there's also this fairly rare thing that
happened to me when I was practicing for
the boss guide Maria can stagger and
riposte you if you get hit by this
specific double bladed attack it almost
looks like she's holding you close and
whispering something in your ear before
she rips her fist out of your chest when
you do defeat Maria take a look at her
death animation Twitter user Hellman
made the observation that it looks
almost identical to Komen's
both characters reach towards the
heavens before falling forward after you
kill Maria you will also get this
dialogue from the doll good hunter this
may sound strange but have I somehow
changed moments ago from someplace
perhaps deep within I sensed a
liberation from heavy shackles not that
I would know how passing strange you can
actually listen to all of the dialogues
from the game on moonlight butterfly's
channel which will be in the description
there's a million things worth
mentioning as soon as we enter the
fishing hamlet most of these things I
found revolve around the villager who
walks towards you initially he has the
same models as most of the spell casters
in the village and there's a lot of
curious things to note about him firstly
you can't actually kill him even when he
appears to have no health left all you
can do is knock him down and feel bad
about yourself as he struggles to pick
himself up of course not to be deterred
I promptly beasts roared him off a cliff
no nevermind he's still walking around
down there if you look closely moving on
he also reacts when you knock over the
small pile of shells near him which is
interesting and one of the oddest things
I've found is that if you watch him all
the way until one of the last piles of
shells then he'll actually start to cast
a lightning spell as he steps over the
shelves I don't know if this is a
pathing error or something it's weird
this could even be related to how some
of the other lightning spell casters
seem to be casting lightning upon the
other larger versions of these shells
when you sneak up on them why they're
casting lightning upon shelves I have no
idea let me know in the comments below
if you have if you talk to him with the
milkweed rune equipped then he gives a
ton more dialogue and he also gives you
an arcane spell as I've mentioned in
another video also by the way did you
know that this cauliflower head glows in
the dark when you kill the orphan in the
ending cutscene you hear this chant
which is likely spoken by the male
villager at the start but this dialogue
and the chanting in general it isn't
that unique after you kill the orphan
and the rain goes away you can hear the
chants of the voices in the huts more
clearly here's what I think they're
saying
mother is dead her baby taken of all the
dialogue I strained my ears to hear I
feel like this is the most significant
the notion that the orphan of cause was
taken from the corpse is novel
information in and of itself and it
follows that the hunters had something
to gain from stealing the orphan three
thirds of an umbilical cord perhaps I do
have to do some more thinking on this so
we'll get back to it in another video
but at the very least it explains why
the villager at the start pleads for
mercy upon the poor wizened child it's
because the child was taken I would
really love it if you guys went there
and strained your ears to hear some of
this stuff I might be wrong and you
might discover something new for
everybody to talk about you know cuz who
knows what else is hidden in this
dialogue you can hear their voices very
clearly near the petted hanging man
which is the symbol of the hunters and
also the shape of a man whose blood has
gone to his head which seems pretty
appropriate for the curse that was laid
upon the hunters if you ask me I mean
they turn into beasts when the blood
goes to their head so I wonder if the
villagers themselves serve as
inspiration for the alien like statues
in the grand Cathedral I always thought
it was weird that the statues wielded
these long harpoon like Spears which are
pretty much unique weapons to those in
the fishing village but not all of the
fish men in this village are wielding
harpoons though many have scraping tools
that they use to dig through the mud
which explains the powers of these
little orbs that I assume are eggs and
also the piles of the little shells
which are like little versions of the
big shells that the snail girls crawl
out of furthermore you'd be wrong to
assume that these light blue things are
fish they're quite clearly slug-like
creatures when you look at them closely
and they're caught in Nets they're on
the ground they're in barrels and most
interestingly I also found a
Slug being used as a candle here which
implies that they're flammable to an
extent and maybe that they can be used
as fuel I suppose that explains the
flammable barrels around the area as
well some of the stuff you can find by
looking in depth at these things is
pretty insane progressing a little
further I want to point out a tip that
was suggested by many people in the
third playthrough video it's that
finally there is a use for the Sharman's
burn blade if you're having trouble
getting the rakuyo this is probably the
way to do it and finally we get to the
orphan many people have pointed me
towards a video by Aegon of astora who
compared the cry of the orphan to the
cry of gurmann and discovered that they
are the same sound file albeit slightly
altered Aegon has a bunch of great
cinematic lore videos as well so you
should check them out in the description
but back to the orphan being related to
German there is a link here for sure for
one he's wielding a weapon that has the
same sort of shape as Gherman scythe and
also when you kill the orphan the doll
gives you this dialogue undeniably
linking gurmann to the orphan somehow oh
good hunter I can hear gehrman sleeping
on any other night he'd be restless but
on this night he sounds so very calm
perhaps something has eased his
suffering oh and one more thing it's
probably the most amazing thing that I
have ever discovered
you